Eugenie Harvey: Thank you, Kate.
And thank everybody for taking time out of
your busy days to come and hear a little bit
about the work we do through our little organization,
"We Are What We Do.”
You may not have heard We Are What We Do.
It's not exactly a brand that trips off the
tongue.
But, you might have heard of a couple of the
projects, which we're going to talk about
today.
One of which -- or two of which -- are the
books that are on your seat.
Which I hope you've had a chance to flip through.
And if you haven't, please take with you and
read and pass on and enjoy.
And you most likely, I think, will have heard
of a project we did with Anya Hindmarch, which
I'm going to talk a little bit about, a bag
called, "I'm Not a Plastic Bag.”
And if you haven't heard of either or any
of those projects, by the end of this year,
I certainly hope "We Are What We Do" is a
brand which trips off your tongue, because
we are infiltrating your organization, and
working on an extremely exciting project with
you.
Which we're going to talk to you -- or Nick's
going to talk to you about today.
At the risk of stealing your thunder, Nick,
I'm going to say that the name of the project
that we're working on with Google is, "Share
Your History.”
That may be a working title.
I don't think so.
It's sort of, you know, the way these things
do.
It's kind of -- seems to be sticking.
And, in the spirit of sharing your history,
I'm going to begin my talk about We Are What
We Do, with a little tiny bit of my own history,
if you will indulge me.
I am Australian, in case you hadn't guessed.
And I grew up in Australia.
I spent the first thirty years of my life
there.
I had a very, very happy fortunate childhood.
But two things happened to me when I was 12,
which left an indelible mark on me, and I
think have really led me to want to do the
sort of work that I do.
And the first that happened was that my mom
and dad got divorced, which is obviously not
a wildly unusual event, but it was -- as it
always is -- very traumatic for me and my
sister.
And within 12 months after that, our house
had burnt down, and we lost everything that
we owned.
And so, it was a fairly intense period in
my early teens.
And it gave me a very strong sense of the
kind of sadness and unfairness that people
can and do experience every single day in
the world in any number of different forms.
And it made me very determined one day to
try and do something with my life that could,
in some way, ease the suffering or improve
the circumstances of people who have been
the victim of problems like those that I had.
So it's a long time ago, back in Sydney, Australia,
in the 70's and 80's.
I went to university.
I did a mass communications degree.
Enjoyed it very much.
I went and worked at a company called the
Sydney Theatre Company.
I worked in the arts, at a time when we were
launching the careers of some very exciting,
famous Australian people.
Then I went to work for Rupert Murdock in
his big pay, television start-up, which was
called FOXTEL.
It was our equivalent of SKY, and it was a
very, very exciting time in telecommunications
and -- well, business in Australia.
I did three or four years there, and by the
time I hit my 30th birthday, the net result
of those experiences was that I kind of burnt
out.
I hadn't kind of burn out; I completely burnt
And, more to the point, that voice that had
been inside me since I was really quite a
young girl of, you know, wanting to do something
to make the world a better place.
That drive, which I've sort of managed to
keep at bay during my 20's, when there was
a lot of other things to be doing -- a lot
of other exciting things to be doing -- started
to get louder and louder and louder.
"What are you doing?”
You know, "How are you going to make this
ambition of trying to help people come to
life?”
And I had absolutely no idea because, as someone
who'd done a mass communications degree, I
clearly had absolutely no skills or experience
that really, you would think, could do anything
to improve the circumstances of people in
the world.
So I did the honorable thing.
I have, thanks to my dad -- who is a wood-grain
lad -- I have a British passport.
And so, as I approached my 30th birthday,
I took my British passport, and I jumped on
a plane and I moved to the other side of the
world where I virtually knew no one, and no
one knew me.
And I could embark on this mission, or reinvention,
to do this thing which was going to make the
world a better place -- whatever that might
be -- in glorious anonymity where nobody knew
me.
I could kind of fail spectacularly and no
one would ever know.
And the great thing was, I did fail spectacularly
on several occasions.
When I got here, you know, with this determination
to find this new thing to do -- this better
thing with my life -- within you know, I think
six weeks, I was working just down the road
here for a PR agency, having moved to the
other side of the world to get out of PR,
promoting the Australian Tourist Commission's
-- or, well, promoting Australia, effectively
in the run up to the Sydney 2002 Games.
So I was on the other side of the world with
no family, no friends, no money, doing the
job I disliked, and promoting the country
I just moved halfway around the world from.
So it was a spectacular failure at, you know,
reinvention.
So I did that for a couple of years, and I
really was very unhappy.
But the good thing that happened during that
time -- which I look back on really with gratitude
now -- was for the first time in my life -- and
I'm not proud to say this, because I worked
in the media for a decade at that point -- For
the first time in my life, I used to sit down
and read the newspaper.
Because, obviously -- well, the media here
is so fabulous and it's very, you know, so
different to Australia where we just have
one newspaper.
So I was very interested and engaged by this
incredible media that you have here.
And I started to read the newspaper every
day.
Not least, because I didn't have very much
money and was really sort of all I could afford
by way of entertainment.
I managed to have a couple of white wines
I think, too.
But, on the whole, I led a fairly solitary
existence.
And I started to read about problems in the
paper.
And as I said, I've had -- ever since I was
quite young -- had this hope that I would
try and do something to make the world a better
place.
But I hadn't really ever -- if I was honest
-- considered some of the issues, or the
issues that I might be interested or able
to participate in.
And so, reading the newspaper during that
period of time and really forcing myself to
think about the sorts of injustices and problems
and crime and terrorism and this thing called
"climate change", which was, sort of -- back
in 2001 -- starting to come on the agenda.
And to really think about those big issues.
And the first thing that happened was, I became
incredibly dispirited and entirely overwhelmed.
And thought, you know, how naive and foolish
was I to think that one person with a mass
communications degree and a few years of PR
could in any way, shape, or form, have any
impact on something like infant mortality
or slavery or climate change.
You know, there's just no way, really.
And so, I went through a period of feeling
pretty grim about things.
But, as luck would have it, I had a chance
encounter with someone.
And, I don't know if any of you have ever
been kind of scratching around to sort of
make a change in some aspect of your life,
but what I was doing was kind of looking out
for any kind of foothold that I might be able
to get onto this new life -- whatever that
may be.
And somebody came to my company -- I was working
at a different company then, at Brunswick,
a big financial PR house -- who was invited
to a -- they had a forum exactly like this,
a kind of monthly opportunity for someone
to come in from a different company -- or
world -- to talk about their work.
And a man called David Robinson came in and
talked about the charity that he founded in
East London, in Newham, which is called "Community
Links", and which he started, I think, about
25 years ago in his mom's front room when
he was a very young man, and has now gone
on to be an incredible force for community
solutions to problems that are affecting a
very poor part of London.
And I think they help about 50,000 people
every year get back on their feet.
You know, no small feat.
And so, David came, he talked about his work
and the sorts of things that they did.
And he was looking for people to do volunteering.
And he was obviously seeing if anyone in the
room would like to.
So I thought, "Well, that's a good place to
start.”
And I went up to talk to him afterwards.
And I said, "You know, I don't think I've
really got much to offer, but I'm very interested
in your work.
I was very inspired by what you said, and
I'd really love to come out and see your charity,
Community Links, in action.”
So I went out there, and I got to know David,
and I got to know some of his colleagues.
And it was a really eye-opening experience
for me.
I've never really sort of been anywhere near
that far east.
I think I've been further east than Liverpool
Street up to that point -- didn't know it
existed.
And I went out to Kennington.
And I started to talk to David and learn about
the work, and it was extremely interesting.
And I talked to David.
I said, "David, you know, I think I'm like
a lot of people.
I'm a really ordinary person who reads about
problems in the paper, who wants to do something
about these problems, but has absolutely no
idea how to begin, and no confidence that
anything I did do might make any impression
on any number of these problems.”
And he said, "Well, that's very interesting.”
He said, "Because I've been doing some thinking
myself.”
As his charity had come up to their 25th birthday,
and he had -- he said he had come to my company
to give this talk, because they couldn't get
people like me any other way to go and help
them with their work.
And he said when -- that the model for Community
Links is engaging local people who don't have
problems to help local people who do have
problems.
And when they launched the charity in his
mom's front room, he said, "We had more people
wanting to help the people in need than we
had people in need.”
He said, "It was a nice problem to have, but
it was a problem.”
He said, "These days it could not be more
different.”
They cannot get enough volunteers to come
and help them with their work in East London
to help people in real need.
And he showed me some research which substantiated
his experience.
And this is just one stat which I pulled out,
which I think really illustrates the point.
And that is, that back in the 1980's, sixty
percent of people in their 30's remember of
a local community association, club, or other
organizations.
That might be a church or trade union or a
football club or a bridge club or a parent
PTA, something like that.
But today, this figure has dropped to less
than ten percent.
I think it's about six percent.
And I would be interested -- I think, you
know, this room is probably largely comprised
of that age range -- people in their thirties.
And I think -- I'm not going to do a "Name
and Shame" -- but, I'd be surprised if more
than, you know, ten or twenty percent of us
in this room belonged to something.
So we started to think about that, and I realized
that really resonated with me, because I realized
that I was very much one of those people who
was this sort of lost generation back 20 or
30 years ago, I probably would have connected
with something locally, an association or
a club or a charity or some kind of organization
that would have allowed me to participate
in something that would be worthwhile in helping
towards some kind of cause.
Whereas, these days, the thought of joining
something and going regularly on Tuesday night
to a town hall for a regular meeting was utterly
foreign to me.
I just wouldn't consider a formal commitment
like that.
And we could talk about the reasons for that.
I think it's, you know, not particularly scientific.
It's things like: We move around more.
We're busier.
We work harder.
We want more flexibility.
It's a whole range of things.
But the net result is, people aren't joining
organizations like David or many others, and
those organizations are suffering.
But equally, people who have found real purpose
and fulfillment from supporting causes are
not able to find that sense of reward.
So, we started to talk about that, and we
thought there was a real opportunity here
to come up with a way of bringing people together
around big problems we read about in such
a way that wasn't a formal seven o'clock on
a Thursday night commitment, but was a looser
association which would be expressed -- rather
than through an actual regular commitment
-- rather through our behavior, through the
things we do.
They would be the signifiers of membership.
And we started to think about these big problems
of climate change, crime, health problems,
poverty.
And we started to break them down.
And rather than seeing them as these great,
big, massive problems that we couldn't have
any impact on, we started to think about them
in terms of our daily lives and the very small
practical things that we could do each day
that would have an effect.
So obviously -- and we have to bear in mind
this was back in 2002 -- we started to think
about things that would affect climate change.
And they were very practical, simple things
we could do around the way we used resources.
Around any number of very practical things
like recycling, and plastic bags.
And we realized that actually, there's quite
a lot you could do every day.
And that if we could get lots of people to
do these simple things, well, we would in
time affect the outcome of the problem.
But, perhaps, more importantly, we would create
a consensus, a new way of being -- that these
things mattered.
And that would then go on to inform our decisions
which are taken by businesses and by governments.
So, not only was doing the action important
in connecting us and making a difference to
the problem, it created a new way of being,
which would be noted and taken on by others
in authority.
So we started applying that thinking across
a whole range of issues from, you know, you
can improve the strength -- you can strengthen
your community by getting to know the people
in your street.
You can have strong relations with your family
by sitting down and having meals together.
You can avoid spending three hundred million
pounds on cleaning the streets of chewing
gum by not spitting your chewing gum.
Those sorts of things.
And we thought that we were perhaps onto something
by providing people with these very simple
entry points into these great, big issues.
So we came up with this idea that we would
try and create a global movement, a loose
association of people.
Not a formal membership organization, but
a loose association of people who would share
our belief that small actions done by lots
of people could and will change the world
for the reasons I've explained.
So the first thing we did was -- that was
back in 2002 -- and I was still working at
Brunswick, the PR company, and I thought this
was a very interesting idea.
And I thought David was a fantastic and inspiring
and wonderful man.
And I could see that he had gathered around
him a really interesting group of people largely
drawn from the creative industries who were
thinking about this idea along with him.
And I could see that there was the need for
someone basically to turn up to all their
meetings and take notes and write the actions
and chase people up and get the things to
happen.
Otherwise, it would just continue to be these
very stimulating conversations in cafes in
East London, and it actually wouldn't move
on.
So I took a sort of -- well, quite a risky
decision, but it seemed quite obvious at the
time, to quit my job and to take the small
amount of money that I'd saved and to use
that to live on for a period of time and to
join David as a volunteer.
Something I never sort of saw myself as doing,
but I thought, "I'll be a volunteer," and
so I did.
I turned up out at Community Links one day,
or Tuesday, and said, "Well, David I'm here.
I've quit my job.”
I think he was quite surprised, but nonetheless
we started from there.
And that was November 2002, and that was kind
of -- well, that was the start of my formal
association with We Are What We Do in my informal
association.
So the first thing we did was a piece of research.
We asked the question, "What would you ask
one million people to do to change the world?”
Put that in the paper.
We e-mailed people.
We wrote to people.
And we got thousands and thousands and thousands
of suggestions of very simple things.
Because I knew the things that I thought would
make a difference, and David had his views
as well.
But, we were really, really keen to make sure
that what we were proposing was actually the
sorts of things that people were willing to
do.
And we got, I think, three-and-a-half thousand
unique suggestions.
And the most frequent suggestion was "Smile,"
which is nice.
But other things were "Say no to plastic bags"
or switch off lights or turn the tap off when
you clean your teeth or write someone who
inspired you or share a bath with someone
you love.
Whole range of things -- most of which we
threw out -- but a core number we held onto
as being symbolic of a whole set of behaviors
and connecting to a wide range of issues.
Then we had this list and we thought, "Well,
we will put them in a book.”
And I think that was a big shazam: we'll make
a book.
And we thought it would be a little black
and white printed book, and it would sit by
the tiller, and it would have a hundred things
you can do, and it would sell for five pounds.
And that would mark the launch of this global,
social change movement which was about trying
to inspire people to use their every day actions
to change the world.
And we had a brilliant guy who was part of
our development group called Twivy, and he
-- I believe he put the "red nose" in Red
Nose Day.
I believe he came up with the red nose.
And he took me aside after one meeting and
he said, "Eugenie, I think this is all great,
but I think this little book of a hundred
instructions -- because that's what it's going
to be -- it's going to be incredibly boring.
I think you've really got to think a bit more
creatively about how you present these ideas.
I've got some mates who work in advertising
who I think will be quite interested in helping
you out.
Here are the names and addresses.
Write to them." So I did.
I wrote to these six men -- all in their middle
age and quite burnt out, I think -- and said,
"Would you come along and help us create a
book out of a list of several hundred actions?”
And to my surprise, they all said, "Yes, absolutely.”
And so, we began an 18 months creative process,
where we sat down every month with these guys
going through these actions and coming up
with treatments for these very, very simple
spreads.
And then, we had all these treatments, and
then we needed photographers and writers and
illustrators and copyrights and all sorts
of things to come in and bring those treatments
to life.
So we got, I think, about 130 people to donate
their skills to that phase of the process.
We found a publisher, Rebecca Nicholson, who
said that she would publish the book and not
make any money out of it.
We found a distributor, TBS, who said that
they would distribute the book all around
the country and not make any money out of
it.
And so, the only thing we were going to pay
for was the printing, which at a print run
of about 5,000 copies was around three quid
a unit, which was all great.
It was fantastic, apart from the fact that
we decided that the book would be called,
"Change the World For a Fiver," -- the "Fiver"
relating to the price -- and we were determined
that we would keep the price low so that it
would be accessible to as many people as possible.
We didn't want this to be something that price
was a barrier to.
But the problem about that -- as they're rolling
off the printing press -- was that, we'd forgotten
something quite important, and that is the
retailers.
And you may not know this, but the retailers
take a cut and it's upwards of sixty percent.
So we had a very nasty moment where a book
called "Change The World For a Fiver" was
going to have to retail for about six pounds
fifty to break even, [laughter] which was,
you know, nothing short of a PR disaster.
And so, the only thing to do was -- well,
cry obviously in the first instance and go
and have a stiff drink -- and then, somehow,
we got the phone number of the buyer at Waterston's,
and I had been hounding her.
And I rang her up, and I said, "Jenny, look,
we've got a little bit of a problem here.
We actually need you to take this book on
the same terms that everybody else has participated
in the book.”
And she said, "What are they?”
And I said, "Basically, make no money.”
[laughter]
And she roared with laughter, and she said,
"You have no idea what you're asking.”
She said, "The book trade is the toughest
trade there is.
We fight for our margin.
It's just not going to happen.”
And we had one dummy copy of the book at that
stage that was available.
So I said, "Look, can I send it over to you,
and can you show it to your boss, and see
what he or she says?”
And she said, "Well, do.
But it's not going to go anywhere.
I assure you.”
So a very, very nervous couple of weeks as
this five thousand books.
You know, I mean, we -- I don't know how we
were paying for the printing of them.
It was all very dodgy.
Nervous couple of weeks until she rang up,
and she said, "Well, hello," you know, "I
have got some good news.
It's not as good as you want.”
And I thought, "Okay, what is it?”
And she said, "We'll take it at ten percent.
We'll make 50 pence on every book, every copy
sold.”
And she said, "We have to do that, because
it costs us money every time, and we can't
lose money on this.”
And I said, "That's fine.
That is absolutely fine.”
And she said, "And we'll take -- I need to
place an order with you and we'll take 5,000
copies.”
So, in that one conversation, not only did
we solve the small problem of the price in
the cover, but we also solved our first quantity.
And, of course, all the other bookshelves
fell into line, and it became a book that
was called "Change The World For a Fiver"
that sold for five pounds that made us a couple
of quid every time we sold a copy, which was
fantastic.
And that book has now gone on to sell a million
copies around the world.
It's been published in Australia, Canada,
New Zealand, Germany, USA, and most recently,
in Spain.
You've got copies of it, and I hope you'll
take them and you'll enjoy reading it.
But we're very, very proud of that project.
Because, as I said, it represented lots and
lots of people coming together around this
idea of contributing your small bit to make
something far greater than you could have
done on your own.
I think about two hundred people, in the end,
donated their time and talent to that book.
And I always describe that book as dropping
a pebble in a pond.
And, like a pebble in a pond, it made a big
splash.
I mean, it hit all the bestseller lists, and
it got loads of publicity, and it sold lots
of copies very quickly.
But actually, the pebble in the pond isn't
the thing that's changing the world, that's
making a difference.
It's the ripples that it created.
And what excites us is what that book has
started, what it's facilitated, what it's
leading to.
And I'm going to talk really quickly about
a couple of those projects.
Some of those ripples are Al's, like the one
I'm going to tell you about, like the project
with Google.
Many, many of them are done by people in communities,
in schools, in hospitals, in villages, all
around the world doing very simple things
inspired by this idea of small actions done
by lots of people.
So "Plastic Bags", I mean, I hope you all
have seen that project.
The first action in the book is "Say no to
plastic bags".
After we published the book, I went to Australia,
and within the space of 12 months, plastic
bags had gone.
No one was using them, which was extraordinary
change.
And I came back thinking, "Well, if that kind
of change has been made in Australia, it's
going to come here sooner or later.”
And so, we'd started to think about maybe
doing a bag around the plastic bag idea.
And, as luck would have it, Tim Ashton, who
is one of our designers on the book, went
to a wedding, sat next to Anya Hindmarch's
husband, happened to have a copy of Change
The World For a Fiver in his pocket, as you
do when you go to a wedding, showed it to
James, and he said, "Oh, I think this is great.
I think Anya would really love this.
Let's have a conversation.”
So within about two months, the Anya Plastic
Bag Project was borne out of that.
And what appealed to Anya -- and, I think,
is what's important and unique about us is,
she appeared -- the tone of what we do.
She said, "It's just -- you speak about this
stuff in a way which isn't worthy, which isn't
boring.
You're not pointing the finger at me and making
me feel bad.
You're inspiring me." She said, "When I read
your book, I do quite a lot of those actions.
It made me feel good, and it made me feel
inclined to do more.”
And she said, "I think your psychology is
bang on.”
She loved the creativity of the book and she,
you know, she felt that it really sat with
her brand aspirations, just to use a kind
of brand-speak.
And so, it gave us this tremendous starting
point for this project, which went on to be
on the front page of every newspaper.
And ladies camped out overnight outside Sainsbury
stores to get one.
It sold out, I think, within two hours of
launching it at Sainsbury's.
When it was launched in -- Taiwan, I think
it was -- the police came, and they canceled
the launch at Anya's shop, because ladies
were rioting.
They were hitting each other over the head
with handbags.
And so, they canceled the launch of it, because
it was a health and safety risk.
But what this bag did -- and the whole kind
of phenomenon around it -- was it put the
issue of plastic bags fairly and squarely
at the heart of mainstream media, which is
exactly where we wanted it to be.
And, as a result of that -- well, certainly
as a part of that -- supermarkets have now,
since that project, achieved a 40 percent
reduction in plastic bags handed out, which
is incredible.
Now, we don't claim to have been the sole
reason for that.
We are part of a movement, of plastic bags
movement, but I think we can certainly say
that we raised the profile of the issue.
And when we talk about creating a mood to
which businesses respond, that's the sort
of thing that encourages businesses to bring
in new business practices which reflect what
people are saying, what they're doing, and
what's in the media.
And I'll just quickly talk about "Teach Your
Granny To Text," which is our most recent
book.
And it's our children's book, and we're very
proud of it.
The Department For Education rang us up and
said they'd like to give a copy of Change
The World For a Fiver to every school in the
country.
But, if you go to Action Eight? -- Eleven
-- Eight, you'll see why that conversation
ground to a halt.
There was no way, on God's earth, they could
put that book into every school in the country,
which was a disappointment, but obviously,
they had some budget.
And they were keen to find a way of working
with it.
So we said, "Well, why don't we do a children's
book together?" And they thought that was
a great idea.
And the result was this book, "Teach Your
Granny To Text.”
In other words, Change The World, which came
about as a similar consultation with children,
asking them what simple action they would
ask a million people to do to change the world,
and taking their responses and creating this
book.
And "Teach Your Granny To Text" was I think
a favorite suggestion from a little girl called
Erica Ritchie, whose granny lives in Scotland
and who -- her mom and dad had got divorced,
and it was her dad's mom -- and she didn't
see her very often.
And so, when she went up to see her at Christmas,
her dad had bought her granny a mobile phone.
And she sat down and taught her how to text.
And now, they're in touch every single day.
And, you know, she's gone from having a relationship
with her granny -- which is a couple of times
a year for a visit -- to a daily and very
regular exchange of news.
And, you know, if you said to Erica, "Oh,
well done for overcoming the digital divide.”
Or, you know, "You've really overcome your
family breakdown," she'd look at you like
you'd grown a second head.
But that's what's at the heart of that action.
Similarly, my favorite is -- I always tell
this wrong, but I'm just going to tell it
like this today -- from a little boy who told
us he suggests "Walk Your Dad.”
And he said, "My dad's really fat, and I haven't
got a dog.
So now, I'll walk my dad."
[laughter]
Which I think isn't true, but it's just become
a truth in my mind.
And the little boy who wrote "Speak Football,"
which was when he went on holiday in Tanzania,
and he took his football with him.
And he used to go around at the end of the
day and kick the football with the little
boys down the street.
And he wrote and said, "I think everybody
should Speak Football, because I couldn't
understand what those boys were saying and
they couldn't understand what I was saying,
but when we had a football, we all knew what
to do." So charming, charming stories that
are at the heart of this book.
Now, there is a multiplicity of projects I
could tell you about, which -- don't give
me too much encouragement or I will -- things
like partnerships with Virgin Atlantic to
create a book about changing the world from
35,000 feet.
I could tell you about a woman in the Inland
Revenue, the HMRC, who came to talk like this
and has now collected more than 6,000 pairs
of spectacles, because she was so inspired
by the "Recycle Your Spectacles" action in
the book.
And she has a scheme that works out of 94
offices of the Inland Revenue around the country,
and began with a photocopier box next to her
desk.
I could tell you about a man in Uganda, a
teacher, who uses "We Are What We Do" to talk
to people in his village about the practice
of bigamy, and the way the practice of bigamy
-- which is very much part of every day life
and very much encouraged -- it's obviously
contributing to this hideous spread of HIV/AIDS.
And he uses what he calls the "spirit" of
the idea, we "are" what we do.
We get world that we deserve.
It's a consequence of the actions we take.
And he applies it in his community to that
issue.
I could tell you any number of stories, but
I'm going to stop there and hand over to Nick.
We have a wonderful new site, which we'd love
it if you go and have a look at it.
You'll see more stuff about us.
But we want to spend the rest of the time
we have with you talking about the work we're
going to do with you, and I hope you'll find
that really interesting.
Thank you.
And -- I just want to say "Ming, if you're
out there, I'm here because you gave me an
introduction to Sylvia.”
Ming in San Francisco who I saw earlier this
year.
Hi, Ming.
>> [laughter]
>> [Clapping]